es muss unser ziel sein jede
infektionskette verfolgen zu können
dafür werden wir arbeiten wir auch an
einer app und die idee ist dass eine app
dabei ebenhausen kann das deutlich
schneller und effizienter zu machen
mobil von ups die jetzt derzeit
programmiert werden
die ich für extrem wichtig halte die
tracing app ist kann sicher eine
wichtige rolle spielen corona wo ist
denn die vielversprechende corona app
die frage des der app das ist einer der
wichtigsten schlüssel auch auf dem weg
in einen neuen alltag der für viele sie
die große hoffnung auf einen enderes
lockdown street racing app für bund und
länder ist eine app gegen korona schon
lange eine zentral wichtige maßnahme
also einfach die app aufs handy dann
werden wir gewarnt wenn wir kontakt mit
infizierten hatten und wir können alle
wieder raus und zurück ins normale leben
klingt doch super
so einfach ist es aber nicht
[Musik]
in diesem video erkläre ich euch was die
erbringen soll
was sie denn aktuell schon kann bzw wie
sie funktioniert und wir gucken am ende
darauf warum sie uns vermutlich nicht
aus dem lockeren retten wird weil ich
jetzt keine it-experten bin und auch
keine ahnung von kryptographie habe habe
ich mit linus neumann das ist einer der
sprecher des chaos computer clubs über
die wichtigsten fragen gesprochen es
gibt eine ganze menge heilsversprechen
die aktuell mit seiner app verbunden
werden
und es ist natürlich wichtig zu
verstehen wo auch die natürlichen
grenzen dieses ansatzes sind und vor
allem erstmal zu verstehen was soll
diese app überhaupt machen
wir alle wollen dass das aufhört wir
wollen raus aus dem doktor und wir
wollen freunde wiedersehen wir wollen
wieder zur arbeit familie und so weiter
aktuell ist es ja so dass wir alle zu
hause bleiben müssen und weil wir die
kontrolle darüber verloren haben wer wo
wen angesteckt hat wir sind aktuell
nicht mehr in der lage genau die
infektionsketten nachzuvollziehen das
liegt unter anderem daran dass man 14
tage lang ansteckend ist und dass 45
prozent der ansteckung passieren bevor
man überhaupt symptome hat das heißt man
merkt selber noch überhaupt nicht dass
man krank ist steckt aber in der zeit
schon menschen an unsere
gesundheitsämter die eigentlich dafür da
sind genau diesen job zu machen und die
infektionsketten nachzuvollziehen sind
aktuell zum einen überlastet und zum
anderen dauer die methode mit der das
aktuell erfasst wird nämlich in solchen
tabellen relativ lang das ziel einer
tracing app ist jetzt also die
infektionsketten schneller zu erfassen
und dadurch schneller zu unterbrechen
also zu verhindern dass sich noch mehr
menschen anstecken
wie und ob eine app das leisten kann
dazu gibt es ganz ganz unterschiedliche
einschätzungen
eine studie aus oxford legt jetzt nahe
dass eine app helfen könnte aber wie
genau soll das gehen
bei den so genannten trading apps geht
es nicht um gps oder bewegungsdaten
sondern darum mit
wem man kontakt hatte wenn sich dann
also zwei handys auf denen die app
installiert ist länger als 15 minuten
und mit einem geringeren abstand als
zwei meter treffen dann tauschen die
gegenseitig ihre all dies aus und die
werden dann verschlüsselt und
anonymisiert auf den handys gespeichert
ganz wichtig ist dabei das passiert ohne
ortsmarken und ohne irgendwelche
informationen über die person die wir da
getroffen haben es werden wirklich nur
die pseudo avisierten heidis gespeichert
wenn man dann positiv auf corinna
getestet wird meldet man das in der app
diese meldung muss von einem arzt oder
einer ärztin bestätigt werden einfach um
zu verhindern dass der missbrauch
geschieht
und dann bekommt jede person mit der man
in bestimmten zeitrahmen kontakt hatte
eine push nachricht auf das handy die
sagt du hattest kontakt mit einer person
die mit krone infiziert ist und dann
kann sich jeder in isolation begeben und
so wird die kontakt kette und die
weitergabe der infektion unterbrochen
das heißt wir würden so einen app nutzen
um die kontakte unserer kontakte zu
schützen und zwar genau die kontakte die
unsere kontakte nicht haben weil sie die
warnung durch die app bekommen haben
für die tracing app gab es lange
unterschiedliche ansätze und auch
mehrere diskussionen um datenschutz sind
natürlich es geht um hochsensible daten
um gesundheit und darum mit wem man
kontakt hatte die frage die jetzt am
ende immer wieder im raum stand war die
ob die daten zentral also auf einem
server beispielsweise lks oder dezentral
also auf jedem einzelnen handy
abgeglichen werden sollen
die bundesregierung war für die zentrale
variante das heißt sie wollten dass alle
daten auf einem server zusammen fließen
dagegen gab es massive kritik dagegen
gab es warnungen und offene briefe unter
anderem auch von linus neumann und dem
chaos computer club die haben
geschrieben
ein scheitern
wäre unausweichlich und in diese ganze
diskussion krankmeldung dass apple und
google zusammenarbeiten wollen was
bürgerlich alles möglich macht und die
beiden tech giganten wollen eine
schnittstelle anbieten auf der die apps
dann aufbauen können die situation hat
sich am ende darauf zugespitzt dass die
bundesregierung einen zentralisierten
ansatz bevorzugen würde
und apple und google nur einen
dezentralisierten ansatz ermöglichen
würden
apple und google große konzerne die im
prinzip die macht über diese geräte
haben und die sagen können das
funktioniert mit dem gerät und das
funktioniert nicht und grundsätzlich
dieser ansatz einer bluetooth beacon
basierten corona app würde auf einem
iphone ohnehin nicht funktionieren wenn
apple nicht zugeständnisse gemacht also
kam es zu 180 grad wende im
gesundheitsministerium aus zentral wurde
dezentral und so soll die app jetzt
kommen
gleichzeitig hat die bundesregierung die
gründe die sie zum zentralen ansatz
geführt haben nicht aufgegeben und zwar
sind das zwei wünsche a einlernen dieser
app zu ermöglichen durch feedback so
dass die app also wenn sie in der ersten
woche entscheidung getroffen hat in der
zweiten woche jan der validierung krieg
zum beispiel über testung der person ja
hat sich der verdacht erhärtet dass
diese person einem risiko ausgesetzt war
oder nicht
und dass durch dieses feedback die
entscheidungsqualität der app natürlich
gesteigert werden kann ganz klassisches
machine learning und das zweite ziel was
die bundesregierung verfolgt ist
natürlich bessere aufklärung über den
verlauf der pandemie zu bekommen
im zentralisierten ansatz werden diese
beiden ziele sehr teuer erkauft nämlich
mit einem zentralisierten monitoring der
bürgerinnen und bürger im dezentralen
ansatz ist es möglich zu sagen okay gebt
uns doch diese daten wenn ihr möchtet
freiwillig und wenn ihr nicht möchte ist
auch in ordnung bekommt ihr trotzdem wie
der teufel steckt auch hier im detail es
ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass es zu
weiteren datenschutzproblem kommt aber
so wie die app gerade geplant ist es sie
keine
datenkrake dafür dass die app wenn sie
denn mal da ist überhaupt was bringt
gibt es einiges an voraussetzungen damit
diese überhaupt wirklich einen einfluss
auf die infektionsketten haben kann
müssen wirklich viele menschen diese app
nutzen
expertinnen und experten rechnen damit
dass ungefähr 60 prozent der bevölkerung
die app nutzen müssen und auch immer an
haben müssen und dass herr lena bei sich
haben müssen 60 prozent das sind
ungefähr alle smartphone besitzer in
deutschland aber nicht mehr jedes gerät
jedes smartphone in deutschland ist
überhaupt aktuelle der lage des
bluetooth low energy zu nutzen und
manche wollen sich die app vielleicht
auch einfach nicht installieren
laut aktuellem zdf-politbarometer werden
47 prozent bereit diese app zu nutzen
das sind aber immer noch zu wenig und
das ist ein zentrales problem
bislang steht aber ganz klar fest und
das wurde von mehreren politikerinnen
und politiker an ganz vielen stellen
betont die app soll freiwillig sein
das heißt niemand wird dazu gezwungen
sich die app herunterzuladen und deshalb
braucht es vor allen dingen eins
vertrauen in diese app wie stets darum
dich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt gibt es die
app noch nicht ich werde natürlich der
app unter die haube schauen ich werde
sie mir genauer anschauen und werde dann
meine entscheidung treffen aber die
zentrale richtungsentscheidung die war
ja jetzt schon die richtige es wird auf
jeden fall jetzt sehr viel schwieriger
noch fehler zu machen die mich am ende
davon abhalten würden die selbst zu
nutzen
stand jetzt erwartet uns datenschutz
mäßig keine katastrophe
dezentrales tracing es selbst für
experten die beste möglichkeit selbst
wenn wir das alles hinbekommen und eine
app auf den markt kommt der mann
datenschutzrechtlich trauen kann die
sich so viele menschen runterladen wie
notwendig bleibt trotzdem die frage was
kann so eine app überhaupt leisten
auch diese frage hat unendlich
die facetten eine ganz entscheidende ist
aber wie stabil und wie zuverlässig ist
überhaupt die technik die den ganzen
zugrunde liegt nämlich die bluetooth
übertragung dieses verfahren wurde noch
nie dazu eingesetzt und es ursprünglich
auch nicht dazu gemacht abstände genau
zu messen und zb zu unterscheiden
befindet sich jetzt eine glaswand
zwischen person a und b und wie weit
sind sie wirklich voneinander entfernt
also wie stark sind die signale stärken
wo ist das handy wiederum halte ich dass
das hat alles auswirkungen und
dementsprechend kann es auch
auswirkungen auf die messgenauigkeit
haben expertinnen und experten für
künstliche intelligenz sind jetzt
relativ optimistisch dass man das der
app trainieren kann das heißt dass die
lärm kam wirklich die abstände relativ
genau einzuschätzen expertin experten
für funktechnologie sind da skeptischer
ganz sicher so dass wie jedes
messverfahren insbesondere hier eines
was noch nie gab und dass in kurzer zeit
für große teile der bevölkerung
ausgerollt werden soll
das hier ungenauigkeiten bleiben werden
ich kann mir vorstellen dass wir hier
mit so einer gestützten erfassung am
ende leben werden wo die app vielleicht
nach fragt hast du hier gerade einen
kontakt kann es mal kurz verifizieren
oder dass wir am ende eben auch nicht so
genaue daten kriegen und am sondern uns
ein bisschen bei der gedächtnisstütze
geholfen wird so etwas wie hier am
mittwoch um zwischen 17 und 18 uhr
evaluiere mal ob du da wirklich die
ganze zeit vielleicht der gesichtsmaske
auf hatte ist auch das ja etwas was die
app nicht erfassen kann
das heißt fehlalarme können also nicht
ausgeschlossen werden
da kann eine falsch betonte app dafür
sorgen dass zu viele leute voll zu
kriegen und das ganze projekt ist
erledigt denn nach dem dritten oder
fünften mal bei dem man unnötig oder
fälschlicherweise benachrichtigt wurde
nimmt man das ganze wahrscheinlich
weniger ernst dieser aspekt das aus
psychologischer sicht sehr wichtig
genauso wie die frage wie die app
überhaupt mit den userinnen und user
kommuniziert so wo stehen wir jetzt also
noch immer ist sehr vieles unklar aber
es gibt zumindest eine grobe richtung
was aber auch immer klarer
die app kann nur ein baustein sein
sehr viel wichtiger bleiben
wahrscheinlich zunächst abstand halten
wenig soziale kontakte hygieneregeln
einhalten masken und ein verbot von
großveranstaltungen die fw sollte
eigentlich schon seit ostern da sein da
kam aber zuerst eine ganz andere app
nämlich die daten spende app für fitness
trecker und smart watch des rk ii und
jetzt möchte gesundheitsminister sparen
auch noch eine quarantäne app das heißt
eine freiwillige app weil der mann
überprüfen kann ob sich die leute an die
quarantäne und an die damit verbundenen
auflagen halten durch das hin und her
und das kommunikationschaos der
bundesregierung geht wertvolle zeit und
vertrauen verloren
für die tracing app an sich bleibt aber
die frage wann kommt sie denn jetzt
wenn wir uns davon ausgehen dass apple
und google uns das für irgendwann mitte
ende mai versprochen haben könnte ich
mir vorstellen dass die in zeit bis
dahin jetzt schon zur entwicklung
genutzt wird dann treten noch ein paar
unwägbarkeiten auf und ich denke wenn
jetzt kompetent gearbeitet wird sollte
juni für so eine app ein launch datum
sein es wird also noch wochen oder
monate dauern
contact tracing über eine app kann ein
baustein sein und weiter zur lockerung
zu kommen aber ich fürchte diese nicht
der heilige gral
wir müssen uns einfach mit dem gedanken
anfreunden dass es keine wunderwaffe
gegen die pandemie gibt auch eine app
ist leider keine und bis man wirklich
nachvollziehen kann was die app denn
jetzt genau bringt werden vermutlich
monate vergehen
also für eine schnelle lockerung und ein
ja wir lassen uns alle die app herunter
und dann geht es zurück in die
normalität dafür wird die tracing
erstmal überhaupt nichts nutzen
[Musik]
ja ich hoffe ich konnte euch ein
bisschen klarheit rein bringen die ganze
diskussion um die korona apps wenn ihr
nichts mehr verpassen wollt ringsum
corona gibt hier oben eine playlist des
heute nachricht kann als mit allen
aktuellen informationen und hier unten
findet ihr die playlist mit weiteren
videos von zoom innen ich freue mich
wenn ihr vorbei schaut